>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> David Plylar: Good
evening everybody.
We are so pleased to have you hear
for this very exciting
concert tonight.
I am here with three amazing
musicians that you will get
to hear doing lots of different
things, lots of different types
of music, just kind of
in extraordinary ways.
They are with the ensemble
Either/Or.
And we have Taka Kigawa, Richard
Carrick, who is a director
and conductor and also
represented as a composer tonight.
And then Jennifer Choi.
And so please join
me in welcoming them.
>> Richard Carrick: Thank you.
>> Jennifer Choi: Thank you.
>> David Plylar: So I
think the first question
that I have is the one that
is on all of our minds.
Is it either or, either or.
>> Richard Carrick: It is either way
you would like to say it [laughter].
So if that gives you a hint.
>> David Plylar: Excellent.
How did. Could you
say just a little bit
about how the ensemble
came together?
And.
>> Richard Carrick: Oh sure.
So the ensemble we started in 2004.
It is co-directed by David
Shively, a fabulous percussionist
and curator, who is
not here tonight.
But we started the group quite
small with three musicians.
And we were really.
We had moved back to New York.
We were in UCSD San Diego
doing our Ph.D. in D.M.A.'s.
And when we moved back to New York,
I had lived in New York before
and I was not necessarily always
hearing the music I wanted to hear.
And I thought well let's just
start playing some of the stuff
that we do not hear
that often in New York.
And that was the, that was
the beginning of the group.
And David and I worked
very closely to kind
of develop this strange repertoire
that we have been developing.
And as we kept going, the group
got bigger and we were able
to do larger shows and very
fortunate to be able to bring
on these incredible musicians.
You have been.
Jennifer Choi has been
with us for 10 years now.
We are very excited.
>> Jennifer Choi: That is right.
This is the 10 year anniversary.
I am really excited.
And also it has been 17 years
since the first time I played
at the Library of Congress too.
So I am feeling really special
today, like extremely special.
>> David Plylar: And what did
you do when you were here before?
>> Jennifer Choi: That was the.
There was a John Zorn portrait.
I do not know if any
of you were here then.
But it was.
Was it 1999 or 2000?
I think it was 2000.
But. And we played the
violin/piano duo [inaudible].
Were you here for that?
Oh wow. So hello again [laughter].
That is great.
>> David Plylar: You have
got a dedicated audience.
>> Jennifer Choi: Yeah.
It is amazing.
And so it is a really
special day for me.
>> Richard Carrick: Fantastic.
And then Taka you must
have joined like about?
>> Taka Kigawa: Compared to
Jennifer, I am kind of new.
Just two or three years.
I am very new.
>> Richard Carrick:
But we are very happy.
And Taka has been amazing as
a chamber musician and also
as a soloist, which you
will get to hear tonight.
And Jennifer also a
fabulous soloist.
So the group kind of keeps growing
and now we do mixed concerts,
either with conducted
chamber ensemble,
small chamber orchestra size,
as well as pretty intense
kind of chamber music.
So you will hear a little
bit of both tonight.
>> David Plylar: And
I think that is one
of the fascinating
things about this evening.
I think you will agree
with me after you hear it.
Is that there is this great
variety of instrumentation and types
of music that you will hear.
But it actually coheres
I think really well.
I am assuming that is just
because of great programming.
But. So that.
But it is really something.
And I thought maybe we could
talk a bit about the program
and you know just kind of get
into each piece a little bit,
maybe starting with the
first one, the Braxton.
I understand that that has
been quite an experience
to put it together.
A lot of people assume
that you just look at it.
If you are not a musician, maybe you
just have a score in front of you
and you use that as a, as a
way to get, you know translate
from what you see on the page
to how you play and that is,
that is still what you do kind of.
But what is different
about it with the Braxton?
>> Richard Carrick: Yeah.
Well first of all I
would like to point
out that the score is actually here.
So I really encourage all of you
before you walk into the concert
to please look at the
[inaudible] with any Braxton score.
There is also some of the Ligeti.
But the Braxton score in particular
is probably something you have not
seen before.
Because he invented it all.
It is amazing this guy, how
he, he comes, he comes from it
from a performers perspective,
from an intellectual perspective,
from a sound perspective
and from a game almost kind
of like improvising perspective.
And you see that in the score.
So did you want to say a
little bit about the score?
>> Jennifer Choi: Sure.
So this is his composition
number 222.
And he, he wrote this in 1995.
And it was, it was after
he was, he went to a course
on Native American music.
So he called it the Ghost Trance
Music -- this particular piece.
And he was really interested in
the ritual dance music and music
for other purposes than
just in the concert hall.
So he is going for that.
And then there is specific
symbols, like circles and triangles
and squares that come
out of a note head.
And that is where we are
supposed to start improvising.
And then we have to find each other
also in the score out of that.
And come back to the Ghost Trance.
So the piece actually could
go on for about 24 hours.
We have to do it today
in like 10 minutes
or something like that [laughter].
But that is what he wants.
He wants you to.
You do not have to play all 30.
There is 30 pages or 33.
I forget how many pages now.
Yeah there is 33.
There is no way we could do all 33.
He does not expect you to.
But you do have to
make some choices.
And that can be either
very, very difficult or.
I actually think that is
difficult to make these choices
with the material that is given.
But that is what we had to do.
>> Richard Carrick: Yeah.
And one of the things he does
is he sets up many paradigms.
So you can, you can pick and choice
at different points
what you want to do.
But you do not know what the
other person is going to do.
And for example, there is a
symbol, which is a circle.
He might attach it to a note.
But then there is also a
symbol, which is a triangle.
And there is a symbol
that is a square.
They all look pretty similar, right?
But the circle means you improvise.
The triangle means you stop playing
that piece and you immediately go
to another piece that he has
written in composition 222.
And the square means you
can stop playing that piece
and immediately play any other
piece he has written [laughter].
So it is pretty open.
>> Jennifer Choi: And actually
in the case there is a score
of the tertiary material.
It is numbered one,
two, three and four.
So those are more specific
and he wants you to go
through them like note by note.
So we do. We chose.
I will just give you the secret in.
But we chose two of
them to play tonight.
Not all four.
You can guess which two.
But they are all displayed there
in the cabinet, which is nice.
>> David Plylar: So if you
can go to these other pieces,
does he do anything special
with the clefs or something?
Or can you just pick any
line from those pieces?
Or?
>> Richard Carrick: Yeah.
He. He believes that all
of his music can be played
on all instruments at any time.
So he has got this really
interesting synthesis.
Braxton comes from many
traditions you know.
Some of you are probably thinking
oh this relates to Cage in a way.
The improvisation thing might
come out of a jazz tradition.
Stockhausen was a big
influence on him.
And he cites that in
a number of examples.
So he is really going deeper with
a lot of these ideas that were
around when he was performing.
He is an incredible musician.
And, and he would just kind
of put them all together
in this unique way.
So how do you notate for
any instrument at any time.
So you still use the five line
staff, but he uses his own clef.
And you can do it in treble clef.
You can do it in base clef.
You can do it in treble clef
three octaves higher or lower.
You can do it in alto clef.
You can switch from one note to
tenor to soprano to alto clef.
>> Jennifer Choi: And that
is called the diamond clef.
And you will see the diamond, right?
>> Richard Carrick: And he also
does that with accidentals.
He has a star accidental.
It could be a flat.
It could be a natural.
It could be a sharp.
And we do not know what
each other are going to do.
>> David Plylar: Do you find
that you play it differently
as you are doing it?
Or do you, do some mapping
and some spontaneous choices?
Or?
>> Jennifer Choi: Yes
and no [laughter].
Because either way can
be frustrating, right?
So you are trying to play
everything on the page
and that almost got more
frustrating for some reason.
Then when we decided to open it up
-- oh that sounds good for today.
And then we tried the open way
to, you know in the next rehearsal
and it was oh well it
sounded better yesterday.
I wonder why?
So I do not know.
Maybe he wants you to just
be listening constantly
and on a dime have to be able
to switch, devise some structure
within the piece by yourself.
And definitely interpret,
interpret, interpret the whole time.
So.
>> David Plylar: Well that is great.
I should mention that this
piece that we are going
to hear tonight was commissioned
by the Library of Congress,
The McKim Fund in the
Library of Congress.
So we are very excited
to have it played.
I do not believe it has
been played in Coolidge
since it was premiered here in 1998.
So this will be a treat.
>> Richard Carrick: Well it is
an honor for us to play it here.
We are really excited.
>> David Plylar: Well
the next piece that comes
up on the program is
one of Richard's pieces.
And maybe you can just
give us a little bit.
I understand that this piece
has multiple [inaudible]
in which can be performed.
>> Richard Carrick: Oh right.
So this. I was very interested in.
you know most of the
composers on tonight's program
as well reflect this as
a systems based approach.
So you kind of have a logical
form and a logical way of dealing
with pitches and kind
of working things out
and creating incredible color
and intensity through that.
And in this.
I come out of that
tradition compositionally.
But in this piece, I was very
interested in creating descriptions.
I was influenced.
You can read in the program
notes, but I was influenced
by [inaudible] the stranger and
specifically the scene the end
of the first chapter or the
first part where [inaudible] is
on the beach and he
sees the stranger.
And then there is this, this.
He sees the sun.
He sees the sweat.
And the shimmering light.
And he has this act,
this murderous act.
And the intensity, in which
that scene begins is incredible
because it begins on this
beautiful beach in Algeria.
And it is very calm.
And there is somebody in the back.
And this is the only time music
is referenced in the whole book.
There is someone playing
an out of tuned flute.
And they are only kind of
getting three notes out of it.
And they are just kind of
cycling through these three notes.
And I thought that is a
fascinating place to start.
So I kind of put the flute
as the description of kind
of what is going on around there.
And then I had the cello and
base clarinet representing kind
of the inner turmoil of the scene.
So one is expressing the outward
serenity or absurdity and the.
And then the lower instruments
are kind of the emotional grit.
And these two kind of coincide.
They first start off very
separately and they come together.
>> David Plylar: You know one
thing I noticed just listening
in rehearsal was that --
[clears throat] excuse me.
As you mentioned, there is this.
You have these pairs and they are
actually often playing near unison
duet type materials together.
But they are just slightly,
like the [inaudible]
of the flute is a slightly off
in terms of pitch maybe, but.
Or doing slightly more ornamentation
or something like that.
>> Richard Carrick: Right.
>> David Plylar: Almost like a
camouflage type of [laughter].
But
>> Richard Carrick: I
have not heard that.
>> David Plylar: But.
Can you say a bit more about that?
Because I think that is a
really intriguing aspect of it.
>> Richard Carrick: Well.
So the flute does this thing
where the flute is out of tune,
but then the piano is kind of
in and out of that tuning world.
And so you know sometimes it
sounds like the flute is in tune
and the piano might be out of tune.
And getting into this place where
it kind of dimensionalises each
of the characters a little bit more.
So you are not just playing together
all the time, but you are kind of.
There is a similarity here with
the Braxton I think you know.
And you will hear it,
I think in terms
of the continuity of the concert.
The parts are all notated in my
piece, but we are kind of going in
and out of each other
compositionally and sonically.
>> David Plylar: It is a
really beautiful piece.
Do you. You also have it
for another arrangement?
>> Richard Carrick: Right
it was originally written
for a piccolo and cello.
And then we actually.
We premiered it on violin and piano.
And tenor saxophone and
musical saw [laughter].
And in this version it
is for flute and piano.
And base clarinet and cello.
So. But again this.
There is this interesting thing
where these melodies
and these fragments are.
They are interesting in themselves,
but it is actually every
instrument can bring so much color
and difference into the quality.
So that is why I have been.
I do not do it that often,
but in this particular case,
I have orchestrated it
for different instruments.
And explored the richnesses
of those instruments.
>> David Plylar: Fantastic.
So the. Maybe we can talk about
the four as the two together.
Because they are two
remarkably pieces
in very different ways I
think that you will find.
One is kind of.
I think one his classic works
now is Spur that we will hear
at the end of the first half.
And the other.
This is the D.C. premier I
think of a clarinet quintet.
So the first one is for
piano and string quartet.
And the other one is for
clarinet and string quartet.
There is a lot to say
about these pieces.
But maybe one thing
that strikes me is
that although they
are very different.
The first one is almost full of
phrenetic activity and energy.
The second one does not
seem to be at first.
But yet there is this kind of
latent energy in both that.
So maybe you can speak about what
is like to perform these pieces.
>> Jennifer Choi: Taka, you want
to say something about Spur?
[Inaudible].
>> Richard Carrick: Starting off
by saying something about Spur.
Spur is a piece where the piano part
is rapid 30 second notes throughout.
And the string quartet are also
kind of this dual personality.
They are completely integrated,
but they almost never
play exactly the same.
It is. It is.
It is incredibly difficult.
Because you know normally
you have downbeats together
or something like that.
And he does not do
that in this piece.
So it is kind of a meta-listening,
I think is happening here.
>> Taka Kigawa: Yeah.
It is also interesting to know
that he put specific [inaudible]
for piano and the string quartet.
He did not put for piano quintet.
So piano and string
quartet playing together.
But I always feel like when
the performers are rehearsing,
where am I?
Am I playing with the string quartet
or very string quartet those
four boys and girls playing here?
But I am like here.
We are together, but at
the same time not together.
Very peculiar experience anytime.
Yeah. Sometimes I feel like when
discussing string [inaudible]
discussing phrasing or [inaudible],
I feel like I am nowhere.
I feel so helpless.
But at the same time, we
are really playing together.
So very strange feeling.
>> Richard Carrick: So if you were
off, it would definitely feel off.
So it [inaudible] where
you have to be exactly
on for it to feel correctly off.
>> Taka Kigawa: Exactly [laughter].
Very, very right.
>> Jennifer Choi: And I think
that is, that is how he works.
We had. Each of us has
had a opportunity to work
with him on a different level.
And when he came to New York City,
I was doing a large ensemble piece.
So we had pretty much
a full orchestra.
And he was so specific about
every dynamic that he wants.
Every nuance.
Every extended technique.
And I was sitting, I
think, somewhere in the back
of the first violin somewhere.
The very back.
And he is listening from
kind of inside the orchestra.
And he said, okay everybody stop.
And he pointed me out and he said,
you are playing too loud [laughter].
It was like well everything
was supposed to be PP
or PPP or PPPP, whatever.
But he could hear that.
So that is the extent of
how meticulously he writes.
Now you might listen to it and
think oh well you know this could be
like an improvised thing.
We have a lot of Pizzicato's
and like you know somebody
plays here and then here.
It is like doot, doot,
doot, like that.
But it is not.
It is like you have to
really have it in your body.
The rhythm in your body.
So for that piece for sure.
>> Richard Carrick: You know another
interesting thing about this piece
that I was mentioning to Taka
earlier that in a lot of, of,
for his piano music, he tends
to do these kind of octave,
splaying octaves that go across
the compass of the keyboard.
But also in, almost intentional,
well obviously intentional
because he writes it.
But not wrong notes.
But kind of moving away from
some sort of octave center.
So in this case, it
might be a minor ninth,
it might be a major
seventh somewhere.
But there is this kind of gradual
type of thing that always tends
to snap back until finally
it shifts or something.
And it is kind of this amazing thing
to listen to over time, I think.
And it is.
So I am really excited about it.
>> David Plylar: How
would you categorize.
Or not categorize.
But think about the clarinet
quintet compared to that piece?
>> Jennifer Choi: Okay.
So in the clarinet quintet,
which was written in 2013,
he is exploring something
completely different.
So he is. He wants to stretch
time, especially in the beginning.
He wants the whole.
The whole piece is around
30 minutes actually.
In the first 15 minutes,
that is half of the piece,
he is trying to do
everything in slow motion.
That is the whole point.
And Interno al Bianco [assumed
spelling] is, it is a reference
to a piece of literature actually.
An Italian piece.
And actually he says it does not
have to do with the actual title.
But he is exploring light
and all sense of light.
But you have to imagine in all the
colors and all the distinctions.
And he is trying to make.
If light were to sound
like something,
this is what it would sound like.
So we are supposed to try to find
this place in our string playing
and also in the clarinet
where we blend.
But it is a certain sound that
maybe you have not heard before.
And he just stays there
for 15 minutes.
That is, that is a big deal.
And then the piece starts to evolve.
I do not want to give
everything away [laughter].
>> Richard Carrick: But one
of the fascinating things
about that piece -- I, I
hear the piece, I think,
I think he wrote it
last year actually.
>> Jennifer Choi: Oh is that right?
>> Richard Carrick: Because it
was just premiered in September
and then we premiered in...
>> Jennifer Choi: Sorry 2015.
>> Richard Carrick: In the U.S.
a few weeks ago in New York.
And this is the, as you
said, the D.C. premier.
And I think it is a
new phase in his music.
You heard the last few
pieces from 2013 to 16,
there is a change going
on in his music.
And in this piece it
is pretty full blown.
One of the things that happens
is acoustics become so important.
In the way that in Spur it is all
about these little motives, bop,
bop, bop, bop, bad da
da, bad da da, you know.
This kind of phrenetic
micro-intensity throughout the
whole piece.
But in Interno, the piece really
opens up and the acoustics
and the sounds of the instruments,
the way they are interacting
with each other sonically
is phenomenal.
It takes such concentration
to kind of play these pieces.
And there is also something about
how long the piece is you know.
We tend to hear.
It is a funny thing, like do you
think you would hear the same.
Let's say we took the first
30 seconds of a piece.
I have never tried this before.
But let's say you take the
first 30 seconds of a piece
and then you hear it at
the beginning of the piece.
It means something.
But if you heard that same
30 seconds three minutes
into the piece, it might
mean something else depending
on what came before.
If you take the first 30 seconds
and you hear it 15 minutes
into the piece, you could
imagine how that same piece
of music would have a different
meaning because of its context.
And I think what he does in
this piece is he stretches
out the scale a little bit to the
point where we really get lost
in this slow expansive music.
We are no longer just
waiting for it to get fast.
It is. That is where we are.
And we start to hear the music
differently for that reason.
>> David Plylar: You know another
thing just to point out, is that,
as you just said, it
stretches out the scale --
literally he does that with
the scales going up and down.
So sometimes they are with
micro tunnel types of.
They are slow glissandi between,
which I would imagine would
be difficult to control.
But there is this kind of.
And actually the same
kind of thing is happening
at a much faster rate in Spur.
I think not actually a faster rate,
but just there is this upward motion
that kind of occurs in both.
But some of the strings are going
down while the others are going up.
And it is something that
kind of creates this.
These moments of interaction
that you can kind of anticipate.
But you are not quite
sure how he is going
to handle each interaction
like that.
>> Jennifer Choi: Exactly.
>> Richard Carrick: Well the,
the glissandi that you
are talking about, David,
is maybe over a six second period
he asks you to do a glissando.
But it is from E to E
quarter flat [laughter].
It is not even to E flat.
So you know.
And then in rehearsal they
are like I think you got
to that E quarter flat a little
bit too early [laughter].
After five seconds instead of six.
So the level of listening
that is going
on when they play is pretty intense.
And.
>> David Plylar: So if you hear
an E flat, it is wrong [laughter].
So yeah. I mean these are,
these are fantastic pieces.
I think you are going to
enjoy them a great deal.
And just before we get to that
final [inaudible] quintet,
we get to hear a selection
of five Ligeti etudes.
I have to admit I am
a big Ligeti fan.
So this is an exciting
moment for me personally just
to be able to hear these.
And Taka maybe you can say a bit
about why these particular ones.
Or just your experience playing
because you play all of the etudes.
>> Richard Carrick: Taka has given
many performances of the whole set.
And so we are very excited to
be able to share some of these.
>> Taka Kigawa: Thank you.
Tonight five only.
Sorry [laughter].
But yes. Like David, I
am a huge Ligeti fan.
I have been playing this set
of piece more than six years
or seven years, maybe 10 years.
As soon as he is published,
I got a score
and start practicing and enjoying.
It is so original and
of course difficult.
I am sure everyone
here, most of you know.
At the same time, very fun.
Very rewarding.
Very good musical experiment.
Just to practice for
yourself and performance
in public like festival to me.
So. And to.
For this concert, because
of those five pieces,
I try to pick most
interesting, fun, interactive
and musically meaningful five.
So I picked [inaudible].
And once [inaudible].
And open strings [inaudible].
And [inaudible] there
was a staircase.
These are five difficult pieces.
Each one is difficult.
But I try to create a, create a
program of five sets as a coherent
in terms of how many tempi
[phonetic] and also structure.
So that is how I chose
those five pieces.
>> David Plylar: So one thing
I can say that is, maybe,
at least what I hear from a, at
a surface level is that the first
and the fifth have a lot
to do with upward scales.
And the second and the fourth
really emphasize the fifth.
Not the fifth pieces,
but the interval.
>> Taka Kigawa: Yeah its interval.
>> David Plylar: And then
that middle one is just one
of the great ones and that
is the more descending scale.
>> Taka Kigawa: All
chromatic descending.
And also polyrhythm.
It is a very important factor
when it comes to Ligeti.
So right hand playing
this rhythm bop, bop, bop.
Left hand -- dat, dat, dat.
And both hands -- dad,
dad, dad, dad, dad.
So lots of rhythms going on
at the same time [inaudible].
>> David Plylar: The
layers are incredible
because you hear these
distinctive scales going down.
But to imagine playing them
actually is quite something.
>> Taka Kigawa: So very original
kind of rhythmic in management.
>> David Plylar: I mentioned to
Richard when we were first talking
about this that when I first got the
music, just to take a look at it.
The first book -- it was all.
It was the facsimile of the
hand written manuscript.
When you learned these, did
you learn from [inaudible]?
>> Taka Kigawa: Manuscript.
Yes. So I literally used
a magnifier [laughter]
because his handwriting is very
small and not so easy to read.
So.
>> Richard Carrick: Well
he was one of the composers
who I do not think anyone
had a ruler in, like when.
He never used a ruler.
So every stem kind of
look like a note as well.
It was incredibly,
incredibly challenging to.
>> Taka Kigawa: Very challenging.
>> Richard Carrick: And
tiny, like you said.
>> Taka Kigawa: Exactly.
>> David Plylar: So do you
still use that [inaudible].
>> Taka Kigawa: Oh no.
I am using a printed out.
I mean. Yeah.
Yeah. Just like you
can see in the hallway.
>> David Plylar: But
there is something
about reading from a manuscript.
You get a different, you
get the composers intent.
You know the way.
Where they put symbols.
The closer they put it to a note or
how they indicate important moments.
You get that from the manuscript.
And then when it is engraved,
you might or might not get it.
So having started with the
manuscript it is usually more work,
but it is often more
rewarding in terms of figuring
out your own personal
interpretation.
Because you have to not
only play these notes,
but you have to internalize
them and that is
where the interpretation comes from.
You have to be yourself
inside of the score.
>> Taka Kigawa: Oh by the way,
[inaudible] are still using,
I mean handwriting
[inaudible] computer.
>> David Plylar: There
is also something
about Ligeti in terms of the.
Oh maybe we are going to
get to this in a second.
But in terms of the program.
Because I guess his pieces are
probably the oldest pieces.
But in some ways I feel
like Ligeti's music has.
You see his effects as a
master composer as someone,
I think in different ways,
kind of influenced everyone
else on the program.
You know, very interesting
because you, you hear the kind
of perpetual rhythmic
quality in the Braxton.
You sort of Aldatire
[assumed spelling].
We have not spoken about her yet.
But I think she was very
influenced by his more spacial
and micropolyphony qualities.
And then the [inaudible]
I think there are
so many relationships
with the Ligeti.
So you know one of the things
to think about when you listen
to the concert is like how
are these pieces interrelated?
What is a common thread?
What is not?
Where do they spread apart?
I always find that interesting.
>> Taka Kigawa: So Ligeti
is the key [laughter].
>> David Plylar: Well it
could be one of the keys.
Or Braxton could be one of the keys.
You know.
>> Richard Carrick:
If you see a square,
you switch to Ligeti
really quickly [laughter].
>> David Plylar: But I inadvertently
skipped over the piece Rowe.
You guys should consider
changing your name
to Either Rowe for
that one [laughter].
But only if you play it backwards.
But maybe you can say a
little bit about this piece.
Because while it is a different sort
of work on the program, it does,
as you say, have a, when you
just mentioned micropolyphony.
It has again like kind of this
internal energy that is trying
to come out of the sound it seems
like as you are listening to it.
Even though it has this, you
know the title of Serenity
and the feeling of that in a sense.
There is this kind of energy
that is bubbling out of it.
How do you.
Or maybe you can just
say a few things?
Did you work with the composer
at all with this piece?
>> Richard Carrick: We did.
We had the pleasure of working
with Anna Thorvaldsdottir,
who is a young Icelandic composer.
And she is currently very busy.
She is one of the young composers
with the New York Philharmonic.
And her music is being
performed widely internationally.
And we had the pleasure of inviting
her to Miller Theater in 2014
where we did a concert of her music.
And we premiered some of her pieces
and we played this piece
and a few other pieces.
And that was really lovely.
She is a great person to work with.
And one of the things about this
piece is you will hear it is,
it is called Serenity.
So there is some music in
there that is very serene.
But then there is, she also gives
you other things to kind of poke
around in and put that in context.
So there is this kind of a shadow
of expressivity that happens
in the music I feel like.
You know, so she is
creating a stillness,
but she is also eluding
to something else.
And then there are these really
interesting things happening
with the percussion and the piano.
I will not give it away
because you will see it.
And in the beautiful hall here,
you will hear it beautifully.
But it also sets you up for.
You know it is a piece that you,
you might ask yourself while you are
listening to it, what am I feeling?
Am I, am I feeling serenity?
Am I experiencing serenity?
Is this piece alluding
to an imagine serenity?
Or is this piece just referencing
her state of mind when she wrote it?
You know these are all interesting
questions when you can listen.
And this is a piece you can really
kind of have your mind focused
on how the music is speaking to you.
>> David Plylar: You
know I do not want.
I hope I am not giving away one of
the things that you are mentioning.
But I was speaking with
Russell a little bit about the,
about the percussion and
the poetic use of wood.
But one of the things
that which you will see.
Well one of the.
It is a beautiful away to use it.
And one of the things that she was
very specific about was the type
of mallet that he would
be using with each
of these maybe unusual
instruments as well.
And so there is this great level
of detail that comes into play.
But the overall.
It is like you have this
combination of, of things happening
at that low level and also
at that broader level.
And it is like you
say is that you attend
to different things just
depending on your state
of mind maybe or something.
Well before we get to some
questions from the audience,
maybe you can say a bit about
what you might be up to next?
Like what is next on the agenda
for the ensemble and individually?
>> Richard Carrick: Well we are
constantly evolving as a group
and always looking to do programs
and work with composers and venues
that kind of put us in
a new place you know.
So we are working with a
Swedish/Dutch composer in April.
We will be flying to
Sweden next month.
A few of us are going.
And we are premiering
his big piece there
with another group there
called Ensemble Son.
And then we are coming
back to New York in April.
And that is kind of the next thing.
But you know the group.
The core of the group
is actually the fact
that we have these
incredible soloists.
It is not just chamber music.
It is chamber music
made with soloists.
And we are really excited
about that kind of energy.
So we are all kind of doing
many different projects.
You have got a concert
here tomorrow, don't you?
>> Jennifer Choi: Yep.
But that is a different kind of
situation at the National Gallery.
>> David Plylar: Some of you
may be going already to that.
>> Jennifer Choi: Oh just
another composer tomorrow.
Mascal and she wrote a
piece for, that goes along
with a black and white film.
And so we are playing live
string quartet with voice.
It is going to be really
fun I think.
So we are rehearsing that.
But we are often times
working on new music,
different composers, commissions.
A couple of different groups.
Some of us are in different
groups as well.
Have the other violinist,
Paula Garcia
and John Popham have a
trio called Long Leash.
And they will play works for piano
trio but by similar composers.
So it is really nice how we
can bring in our knowledge
and inspiration from the other
times that we have worked
with these composers and
come in to Either/Or.
>> Richard Carrick: I guess I would
say we have a number of recordings.
And we just released
a few recordings.
One with Anthony Coleman, which came
out eelier this year
on New World Records.
And Elliott Sharp.
We are on his latest CD as well.
My CD came out last year
with a recording of that.
And so we have been pretty active
and really fortunate to be able
to put this stuff down
in some sort of.
>> Jennifer Choi: And one other.
We worked with Miya
Masaoka, who is the,
a composer and performer as well.
And she is married to George Lewis,
who is also part of the AACM.
And Either/Or is going
to be performing her work
in March at National Sawdust.
So that should be pretty exciting.
That is the new venue in Brooklyn.
Woo hoo hoo.
Yeah.
>> David Plylar: Taka,
what about you?
What is your next, gonna tackle?
>> Taka Kigawa: Being a pianist,
I have a lot of projects going on.
And. Oh actually I am
playing Richard's piece
in April in New York City.
It is a piece about a
young [inaudible] composers
and Richard Carrick.
And also Sean Shepherd
and [inaudible] and one
or two more solo piano pieces.
That is my next [inaudible] project.
And I also.
I am revisiting [inaudible]
big pieces.
>> David Plylar: The whole thing?
>> Taka Kigawa: The whole thing.
>> Jennifer Choi: That
is a Taka thing.
He does not just do one.
He does the whole thing.
>> Taka Kigawa: [Inaudible] and
I am also revisiting [inaudible]
and also [inaudible].
So. This whole thing
is jabbling [laughter].
>> David Plylar: Wow.
Why don't we take a moment now just
to, if anybody has any questions
for these guys before we let them
go and get ready for the concert?
Jay has a microphone and
he can bring it to you.
Surely somebody has a question.
There we go.
>> So I cannot wait
to hear the Braxton.
The way you described
the improvisation
and the jumping around
and everything.
Is he unique as a composer
in doing that?
Or do, have other composers
done that as well?
>> Richard Carrick:
That is a good question.
Composers have done that.
And improvisation.
You know if you go back
in history, improvisation
and composition were
almost the same act.
I mean very often the composer
in Mozart's time improvise a piece
you know based on these formal rules
and so forth and kind
of deviated from them.
So improvisation and composition
have always been linked.
It is true that since the, since
modern times, you know certainly
in the last hundred years
improvisation has kind
of been weeded out of
a lot of notated music.
But Anthony Braxton does it
in a very unique way I think.
He really wants to setup
this trance you know.
And that is like, that is one of
the great tricks of this piece is --
how do you both be in a trance
and constantly changing.
You know, you cannot do both.
So. So how do you kind
of deal with that?
As a performer what choices do you
make and when do you make them?
But there are many
others who do that.
And as Jennifer said, he is
part of the AACM and many
of those composers, Muhal
Richard Abrams, George Lewis
and many others have been dealing
with a lot of these issues.
And it is not really just
notation improvisation.
It is actually like how do you
find new ways of making music
with performers, with
scores and so forth.
>> Jennifer Choi: Oh the Association
of Advancement Creative Musicians.
So. And they were based
out of Chicago.
And actually to answer your question
further, I had the opportunity
to work with four of these
amazing founding musicians.
So Wadada Leo Smith on the trumpet.
Leroy Jenkins.
George Lewis.
And Anthony Braxton.
And having seen all of their scores,
it is just so amazing how
unique each one of them.
They come from the same generation.
Chicago 1960's.
This is when they formed.
And they really wanted to.
They did not want to play just jazz.
In fact, some of them did not
even have formal jazz training.
Not all of them did.
So. So it is amazing
that each of them came
up with completely different systems
of doing so, of how to do this sort
of quasi structured
improve notated pieces.
Very distinct.
Very interesting.
But also calling for the musician
to definitely improvise and go out
and explore their own world.
>> David Plylar: One thing I would
mention too, if you are interested,
that George Lewis actually two
years ago wrote a biography kind
of the organization.
It is quite big.
So you can check that
out [inaudible].
>> Richard Carrick: It is called
A Power Stronger Than Itself.
>> Jennifer Choi: It is fascinating.
Yeah.
>> Since we are in the Library
and you have so many treasures,
I was very interested in what
you said about the difference
between working on the
original manuscripts core,
manuscript and the final product.
I am sure all of us are aware
that the original manuscripts
core is disappearing.
I know most of the modern
composers do not write, they type.
>> David Plylar: A lot of them do.
Some of them still
do it the other way.
>> Okay. But I think
for future generations
and here comes the Library,
what is going to happen?
>> David Plylar: It
is a tough question.
But I would say that there
are a number of composers
who do still write by hand.
So we will just keep
collecting their stuff
and [laughter] ignore the rest.
No. I am just kidding.
No. It is a tricky thing.
When the Library Commissions any
composer, part of the condition
of the Commission is that we
receive the original manuscript.
So in the cases, and
this has been especially
in the last 10 years this
has been more the case,
that they have electronically
produced scores.
So we try to get a
unique version of it.
And the way that we handle
it is we ask for something
that is before it has been
submitted to the publisher
for kind of the final revisions.
And sometimes composers will
give us little extra bits.
They will give us further revisions
they might make after the fact.
They initial each page so it, you
know there is something about it
that is unique and still of use
to researchers who may have access
to the published score, but
there might be something
to be found in the other one.
But it is definitely an issue and
actually one of the bigger issues is
for composers who have an
electroacoustic component
to their work.
And how does one preserve, you
know, particular technology
that might be common right
now, but 20 years from now,
50 years from now, it
is not going to be.
So that is a challenge that
is a work in progress I think.
>> Thank you and good luck.
>> David Plylar: I
think there is one.
I thought I saw somebody.
Oh there is one other.
>> First I just want to thank David.
You spoil us with your
program notes.
He is a very excellent musicologist.
But he also gets inside
a score very well.
So thank you, David [applause].
And I just want to ask you
as performers of the Braxton
and the other pieces that have
this improvisatory element,
don't you think it is about
trying to keep it alive
that every performance the compeer
is wanting it to be very organic.
And this dialogue between
audience members and performers
and the composer is
all wrapped into it?
>> Jennifer Choi: Yeah.
Absolutely.
There is another book I was just
reading, just the other day.
The. It is called Free Improvisation
by Derek Bailey, who
is just phenomenal.
I am so lucky that I had
a chance to play with him
in New York City before
he passed away.
But he mentions that.
Like in improve you want to
have the audience interact.
You want to feel the
moment right there.
So we cannot really predict.
That is why.
We started practicing today
and I said you know what
let's just see what happens.
Because you need that interaction.
It is actually very crucial to
know what is going to play out.
And we could feel it you know.
But actually there is a,
there is one really good point
that Derek Bailey mentions
in this book
and says sometimes
you do not want to go
with what the audience
necessarily wants
because that might not be
the right move for the music.
So there is this little
interplay and you kind of have
to feel what is right
and wrong at the moment.
>> Richard Carrick: Yeah it
seemed like Derek Bailey.
In reading that book,
I got the sense
that on one hand he was keenly
aware of everything around him.
And on the other hand, he
had his own internal score
that he was kind of creating.
And that was, and that
was the tension
that created all the
incredible, you know.
If you ever hear him play,
I mean you were not sure
if he was listening
to the other person
because he was doing his own things.
Then you realize he was listening
to everything they were doing,
but he was not trying to
imitate the other person.
He was trying to create a richness
from being unique inside
that context.
>> David Plylar: Good answers.
Well I think we should
probably let our musicians go
and get ready for the concert.
But please join me in thanking them
and we really appreciate
[inaudible].
Thank you very much.
>> Jennifer Choi: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.